[Music]
it's a lot of negativity out there who
are saying yay how we gonna stay
positive through all this craziness yeah
there is no answer to that
should we just you know we've done the
podcast market and the clock cast is
over that we're wearing we're in we're
in deep deep trouble here that I would
say that every moment is an opportunity
and as long as you're doing more than
50% of them in the positive you're
contributing to the solution first of
all why is it important to be positive
do we need to be positive what is the
power of positivity there's a lot of you
know self-help shenanigans around yeah
power of positivity the what is that
true I talked about the woowoo section
of the bookstore there yeah there's a
lot of operas like it just stay positive
you know yeah well then that'll solve
all your problems false positives are
not a good idea
now the discerning mind you know which
can be negative is very important I mean
I would really want to have some
negativity towards the idea that I might
be able to cross the yellow line and
pass the truck when there's too close of
an oncoming car all right the negative
my mental attitude is no no I can do
this is the last thing he said so
there's there's times for positivity and
there's times for negativity I just
believe that there's also an opportunity
to be positive and negative times when
you know everything is collapsing
everything is being controlled by
gravity which is that negative force
it's just a natural force negativity
it's not a thing that's bad and
positively is not necessarily a thing
that's good but to be able to be
levitated as opposed to gravitated right
in as opposed to always having to go
down
with that flow being able to be
exuberant is really important in
particular times to balance things out
otherwise it gets pretty grim mm-hmm
well there's there's sort of
performative positivity it's like
looking in a mirror and saying you know
I can do it versus truly inhabiting a
positive attitude like and it's in its
most full expression like really owning
positivity like being positive and
speaking positive words are two
different things what did you call it
you called it performative positivity
wow what a great expression I mean I'm
sure you have to do that often times
when you're running when you're
bicycling when you're swimming yeah
talking yourself into something to do
that all the time would be a real false
positive to do that some of the time is
a real advantage and to be able to have
that tool that when you need it
you can use it is something that is very
important how did you develop that tool
so that when you really had to talk your
way through a place at whatever 14 miles
or 20 miles or whatever it is how did
you develop that tool so it could kick
in well I think it's a combination of
two things there's a little bit of fake
it till you make it which I have issues
with philosophy in general that's
general but in parsha like yeah it's
helpful at times I don't think it's a
good idea to walk around faking it til
you make it with everything I don't I
don't think that's a great life
philosophy but it comes in handy from
time to time and that's something I
learned in in recovery they say it in in
the rooms all the time like fake it till
you make it like if you you know
Alcoholics Anonymous is a spiritual
program but a lot of people come in with
a ton of baggage around
God and spirituality and religion etc
and they have a hard time accepting the
spiritual component of that particular
program and so what is said is fake it
till you make it like just okay so you
don't that's fine just you know pretend
until you can kind of get on board and I
think that works for certain things and
in other areas of life but like I said
is not great all the time so I think for
me there's a little bit of that in the
training and the racing like if you
think you can't do it just what would
somebody who is capable of doing that
tell themselves and what would they do
and trying to mimic that I think it's a
powerful tool but I think the more
powerful tool and what gets me through
those particular moments that you're
referring to is experience like I know
when I'm on mile whatever of whatever
race that I'm gonna be able to do it
because I can think back to a particular
training session that was harder than
whatever moment I'm in at the moment and
hang on to what I did in that moment or
just the pure memory of that is enough
fuel to tell me oh I've done this before
I've been here before
I got through it before I know I can get
through it this time that's the
antithesis of fake it till you make it
because I've actually done it in the
past and I can leverage that memory and
that visceral experience in my
consciousness to fuel whatever I'm in
the midst of in that moment I just
captured a great metaphor when you were
talking from what you were saying you
know you when you're running a car let's
just say that we're not all electric
cars and when you're starting a car you
use the battery which you only use for a
few moments and then you're not using
the battery and then you use the starter
motor which engages and once the engine
is turning over then you're not using
that and so these batteries starter
motors could almost be parallel to that
fecit and you'll make it until you get
something really happening
and the really happening is sometimes
the memory of a previous happening in my
life the idea of being positive and the
negative I've been fortunate enough to
know that there was reasons for both
right so being negative it's a fuel
being positive it's a fuel being
positive in a negative situation is
almost like a match striking against an
abrasive surface you know it can ignite
something and so the idea of these of
these opposites play out sometimes when
you're in a negative situation it's time
to dive even deeper mm-hmm I mean into
the negativity into the negativity yeah
I think I think what happens is
sometimes positivity gets conflated with
denial so what I mean by that is good
point you could be you know a hundred
pounds overweight and you're looking at
yourself in the mirror and you're like
don't worry it's okay you look great you
know it's like no you don't look great
you're 100 pounds overweight
like maybe negativity is the wrong word
but how about just honesty how about
snapping that denial and just being
truthful with yourself like no I'm I'm
overweight like I need to address this
it doesn't feel good to be this
overweight this is a negative physical
state for me and it feels negative in my
body then you can leverage that
negativity as fuel as you mentioned
catalyze change but if you're just
walking around with a blind positive
attitude about everything then you're
missing signals to make changes in your
life that could make your life better
what is it they call Pollyanna Pollyanna
yeah that's that's perfect that's
exactly what it is being Pollyanna
so that's positivity in Pollyanna
positivity in denial these are different
things I'm really touched by the word
denial and I also would think that if we
wanted to realize that some positivity
is
state of like what did you call it again
you call it a performative performative
yeah sometimes positivity is pure denial
imagine that we don't think of negative
as bad and we don't think of positive as
good we just think of them as like hot
and cold water on a shower you walk into
a hotel there's a reason why the thing
when it turns on in the hotel shower
starts out cold is so that nobody burns
themself you know anybody can get cold
water won't cause permanent damage but
the hot water could and so imagine going
into a situation that we don't just go
oh I got to be positive that we may be
Co I got to be receptive I have to find
out is the negativity of being a hundred
pounds overweight right is the
negativity that I'm feeling in that
moment going to be a stimulant so that I
can make change and make make positive
change so that I can make change and
make a change that I really want an
outcome that I really want and is
positivity in that moment going to mask
the true appearance so that I'm not able
to actually engage change right the idea
that positive positivity and negativity
are opposite charges right to allow
yourself to feel that negative influx of
emotion that comes with breaking the
denial that you're 100 pounds overweight
is good as long as it catalyzes that
opposite bokken by to be definitely not
overwhelm not any work if it can
catalyze that opposite positive charge
to say okay I have this problem I'm
gonna own it without any denial I'm
gonna be honest about where I'm at right
now but I can solve this think about it
we run our entire world on negativity
electrons are negatively charged so
meaning like all electronics yes all
Electronics are negatives and that means
not bad right there's a lot of advantage
in gravity
the gravity of a situation there's a lot
of advantage in gravity
there's also advantage in levity and I
think really knowing when positive and
when negative is going to be of greater
value at a moment is a good thing to
aspire to mm-hmm yeah in the same way
that using you're sort of extending on
your analogy of the starter the battery
and the starter engine negativity could
then set in motion a chain of events
that leads you to a perspective of
defeat and victimhood right which would
be the the gasoline engine churning on
the charge created by the negative
impulse yeah or the negative impulse
court could create a positive chain of
actions that set you in a different
direction so they all have their place
very good when you but in sequence but
the engine the gasoline engine to use
the analogy that you want to be turning
on is the positive one and what if you
look in the mirror and you say man I I
look like [ __ ] you know I look horrible
and letting that be a stimulant which is
the starter engine stimulant to starting
up the the main engine trying to stay
away from the word gasoline yeah a
carbon-free you know the gasoline engine
which is the plan that you're going to
do that you're going to run this far
you're going to eat this way you're
gonna do this stuff and eventually
you're gonna drop that excess weight
mm-hmm so you have to hit the negative
in order to get into the positive and
then you have to use the positive to get
you through all of the negatives that
are going to be attacking you as you're
striving to not eat so much you feeling
hungry that's a negative feeling whether
all the setbacks and the obstacles that
are gonna get thrown in your path on the
on the on the trajectory towards
achieving that goal so it's really about
navigation huh being positive
negative world it's really about
navigating the negativity and knowing
when to use which well it's easy to say
ok this is how you should be mm-hmm
this is how you should react this is how
you should look at something this is the
disposition that you should inhabit on
your goal towards losing 100 pounds or
whatever it is but that's very different
than the doing of it hmm and in the
doing of it you're gonna have to get
really negative at some times and you're
gonna have to get really positive but
being able to know how to switch back
and forth so this is what I'm getting at
like how do you do that if you're
somebody who has been in a victim
pattern or somebody who has a negative
disposition or looks at you know the
world like the glasses you know got a
hole that I'm which one is it half empty
full got a hole in it really exactly as
a crack in the glass if those are the
lenses through which you perceive your
reality how does one shift that gently
because usually those kinds of
deep-seated perspectives are genetic
they come from what happened in your
parents life what happened in your
grandparents life what happened in your
great-grandparents life epigenetic
epigenetically it's in your it's it's in
your DNA and I mean I know that I had a
sort of a knee-jerk response to certain
things that would occur that for decades
I was dealing without actually diving in
you know dealing with rather than diving
into and this was controlling my world
not at a macro level but you know on a
micro level of what I was experiencing
when I was when I was working in the in
the world that we all live in and then I
got to in my meditation I got to a place
where I said you know what
I actually start to see the pattern let
me actually work on that a little bit
every day and that's why I say gently
let me work on it a little bit every day
a little bit like a game of pick-up
sticks and then game of cosmic pick-up
sticks
let me move a stick every day so that
the whole thing doesn't collapse and
then let me move another stick the next
day and I had to work my way through
this really deep-seated which is often
nonverbal even non visual non auditory
it's just this sensation that you have
of being of a particular modality I'm
sure you felt it throughout your life as
well yeah of course I mean I I you know
I've had a historic kind of tendency to
catastrophize and you to of course get
footer there is the worst thing that
could ever happen to me I love the word
catastrophe so the way that I've tried
to claw my way out of that preset mmm is
to two different things first of all it
comes with experience like some of the
things that have happened to me in my
life that I thought were the absolute
worst possible things that could ever
happen to me have turned out to be the
best things teachers so I've learned the
hard way to not prejudge situations and
circumstances because we lack the
necessary evidence to make that judgment
we don't do as good or bad evidence
especially when we're in the midst of it
occurring mm-hmm we're not qualified to
make that judgment it's just in the
midst right yeah it just is it's only
sweat the it's sanskrit translated from
the sanskrit it's called viewing the
what is however very what is the
sanskrit word you know the sanskrit word
is protea HOD
uh-huh and it's just basically viewing
being so much in your calm that you're
just viewing the what is without any
attitude right so the practice is
can you be neutral hmm
we're not even talking about being
positive or negative if your preset is
to catastrophize or to perceive a
certain situation when it arises as a
bad thing as a negative thing let's
start with just trying to be neutral
can we not judge it it's harder than it
sounds well look at the look at the yes
it is look at the expressions that have
governed life don't get your hopes up
you don't want to be disappointed right
and being full of yourself
was considered to be a bad thing even
the word ego don't you I you're in your
ego right and even spirituality has made
this ego thing you know just like taboo
but think about it anybody who has ever
achieved anything positive in their life
has had to be a bit full of themselves
has had to be somewhat self-centered has
had to be in their ego think of it as
you're in the psychological form of Carl
Jung and your ego is basically the glue
that holds your being in your body your
you know your conscious spiritual soul
body whatever you want to refer to it as
the energy that's in your body the ego
the expression is what keeps you in and
when you're losing that it's when you
are depressed right so thinking that
along the lines of the negatives going
to be a teacher and the positives going
to be an opportunity being able to work
with both it's a little bit like that
car metaphor we've been using jumping
into a car that's got a great battery a
great engine a great accelerator and no
brakes
but on the tip of the ego sort of you
know celebrating the good aspects of the
ego the countervailing measure against
that always has to be humility yeah
because the ego unchecked will take you
down every single time yeah well I would
I would say this I would say that you're
absolutely correct but learn how to go
down grace
because if you are afraid of using your
ego it's it's mmm and I'm not saying
that this is what in any way shape or
form that you were indicating but it is
what is out there in the world and it's
definitely what's out there in the world
more so on paths of consciousness and so
on paths of consciousness everyone is
afraid of you know being in your ego and
I say err on the side of being too much
in your ego rather than err err on the
side of being too little of your ego and
then find yourself not having humility
and get trashed you know blow it and
then learn from that because and that's
what is ultimately even if it's negative
is ultimately super positive in the
negativity of this world it's like it's
like a plant-based diet in a carnivorous
environment right it's like a carbon
clean attitude in a very you know carbon
dioxide filled you and uh atmosphere I
would say that we should encourage
people to err err on the side of being
in their ego more than not that's a very
counterintuitive perspective though I'm
glad I mean I don't know that I would
have expected you to come from that view
I come from that view because I've seen
too many people in the false positive
which was what you were talking about
earlier am I am i doing the right thing
am I being the right way am i you know M
I and I want to blow off the you know
the shell so that I can fully expose
myself being positive in the negative
and I think that that requires ego I
don't think that I don't think that you
could be the elite athlete that you are
if your ego wasn't stimulated positively
yeah I would grant you that but I think
there's a difference between somebody
who moves forward in the world with a
deep profound sense of their personal
self-worth somebody who's coming from a
perspective of that's it I have
something to say you know my my
perspective is valid you know I believe
in myself and I'm gonna I'm here to
stake my claim versus somebody whose ego
is being fueled by insecurity and lack
and fear who's saying you know all these
people are doing all these things so I'm
gonna make a big brass show of
everything to convince everybody that
you know I should be here but deep down
I know that I probably shouldn't well I
just thought of a great expression so
ego is what I'm talking about
II stopped is what you're describing you
know the brash you know the not humble
person is an e-stop we need to have that
that's a that's a negative ego is
positive and you should and and like you
said you you didn't expect that but I
would say err on the side of making too
much and then learn how to dial it back
mm-hmm because then you're actually
riding on on the point of the wave on
that point of the crest so that your
effort is a bit effortless you gain
momentum all of those important physics
expressions of how to ride the wave of
time I get that I think on the path
there we have to still overcome whatever
negative presets we have so back on that
subject of catastrophizing I love that
the other technique that I would use
that I still use is to play it out so if
your perspective is oh my god this thing
happened
the worst thing ever I can't believe it
it's terrible my life is over to just go
alright well this happened so then that
means that this next thing is gonna
happen and then this next thing is gonna
happen so you're playing it out yeah and
then you're like okay in your mind right
like oh my car my car broke down on the
way to the most important interview I've
ever had this is terrible I'm not going
to get the job then nobody's gonna hire
me and I'm not gonna be able to pay my
rent I'm gonna be homeless and I'm gonna
starve and I'm gonna die but it feels
that miles that is catastrophizing so to
then break that down into its pieces and
say alright my car broke down so what
happens if okay so I'm gonna be late for
the interview worst case scenario is I
don't get hired for this job like well
maybe I'm not supposed to get hired for
that maybe there's because there's a
better job like let's live in the
reality of okay now you've just lost
this job opportunity how does that feel
well I'm still breathing still here you
know that's not great but like but to
like live in all of those eventual
potential realities is helpful to me to
then say no matter what transpires like
I'm not going to die like I will be okay
and it's almost like push-ups for
developing a more neutral and ultimately
a more positive perspective that that
will provide you with the strength to
like crawl out of the catastrophizing
hellhole catastrophizing has got to be a
word that we use a lot of from using it
for a long time yeah well you know a
great teacher Yogi Bhajan once said make
up words every word was made up at some
point and that's true we sort of think
about all words just existed preordained
that's crazy so the idea that you have
this this neutrality the positive and
the negative is also a part of the
actual makeup of the human brain we've
got negative mind which is the
of the brain that is going to look for
the pitfalls and the danger points and
all of that we've got the positive mind
that is going to project I can do this
whatever it is in any moment and then
we've got the one that sits in between
that is neither negative or positive
it's the neutral mind and because the
world is so you know sort of fixated on
surviving and we have this this idea of
the enemy and that which is dangerous or
you know so many industries are just
governed by this idea that are the way
we use our brain has very much gotten
into the negative side of that of that
trilogy
well because it's being stoked by fear
it's being stoked by fear and so the
nature of infinity is that infinity
can't be measured
there is no location and it can't be
multiplied or divided it's very much
like the zero and in infinity every
moment in every point in space is
infinite so what that means is that in
every moment in every place that you are
there is an infinite amount of
opportunity but what happens is that
negativity as you say stoked by fear is
governing the way in which our brain is
relating and epigenetically we are being
programmed we're being programmed in
school we're being programmed
look at this we go to school and we are
told we have to hide our work we can't
collaborate with anybody on a big test
then we go out into the workplace and
it's all about collaboration so we
haven't really been trained in school as
to what we're going to be using going
forward and I have a diagram for this
all right the PowerPoint the PowerPoint
coming out and here so for those
listening he just pulled out a placard
with like magic marker arrows on it yeah
and one is really big and that's the all
inclusive position which includes the
red arrow which are all the danger
points that we really want to keep our
eye on the negative mind and all the
blue are all the positive points that
exist like you were saying I'm still
breathing you know your car broke down
I'm still breathing I won't get this job
but maybe I'll get a better job right
and so what happens is that the
sympathetic nervous system goes oh man
that's the worst thing we could Astra
Faiz with it the parasympathetic nervous
system goes okay that's real it doesn't
ignore that but it also realizes that
there's a lot around that that are
opportunities and so what you know being
positive and the negative is sometimes
just an opportunity of being able to do
a breathing exercise that kicks in that
parasympathetic nervous system to
override the fear impulse the negative
impulse catastrophizing do you say that
that was a part of your world
yeah it's like hardwired into me Wow I
had an interesting thing hardwired into
me and that was that when something was
going to be really great oh what's the
downside and I suppose they're kind of
similar mm-hmm because and I had to
really work to embrace that yeah or like
when's the when's the other shoe gonna
drop exact expression like as soon as
things are going well well it's just a
matter of time before it's all gonna
fall apart that people were trained with
and I know what did you do to overcome
that because I think that's pretty
common i sat with my victim right
because that's what it is right when
things are really great some thing is
gonna happen and you know what is it
wait for the other shoe to drop and I
had to sit and what I did was i sat with
who that was
and then I found out where that was in
the past of my family tree and I found
that this was not something that was an
experience of my lifetime this was
something that was an experience not
only of MA of my parent but my
grandparents lifetime and I'm sure that
it went back farther than that hmm and
so you know a lot of these things that
govern us like the microbes like the
microbiome not only is that microbiome
governing our ways in which we express
and feel and think and talk but also
those experiences outside of time those
experiences from our genetic past are
governing how we view so you and your
catastrophizing and me and my other shoe
is going to drop we had to walk through
you know those years where that was our
governing you know attitude and it
carried us through certain times that
gave us the opportunity to learn some
lessons yeah and these things are very I
mean I'm asking you because they're very
difficult to even confront let alone
overcome so whether you're somebody
who's a constant victim the world is
against you whether you catastrophize
whether you have impostor syndrome
that's another thing that I and I have
to wage war with that's the fraud yeah
yeah the idea that you know they're
gonna find out they're gonna come in
here guru Singh and they're gonna take
these microphones away do you know do
you know that anyone who is being
positive to over ride is feeling that
mm-hmm
and it was really good for all of your
listeners to realize that you to have
that sensation when you're being because
a lot of people could look at you just
like you said a lot of people could look
at me and say well it's gurus saying of
course he's born that way you know but
not really oh I mean this is something I
deal with all the time you know when I
was a lawyer like who does he think he
is being a lawyer then when I become
this athlete well who does this who
this lawyer think he can do this athlete
thing now he's gonna be a podcaster come
on like this is this this is never gonna
work so in the morning he is so
important for people to hear this
because neither you nor I nor anyone
else that has made any kind of a brand
for themselves got there without a lot
of need to be positive in the negative
or to use the negative to be able to
gain momentum like the starter engine in
the and the battery to gain momentum to
get the whole thing rolling mm-hmm one
of the other tools that I use I think we
might have talked about this before but
in addition to you know maintaining
neutrality and then also walking through
all the steps and feeling what it would
feel like in a worst-case scenario
a third tactic that I found very helpful
is to understand that we're all living
in this story that we've constructed
about who we are and that story is based
on isolated incidents that we've
selected for some reason in our mind and
then strung together to create a
narrative that coheres around a
principle like things never work out for
me see this happened and then when I was
12 and then when I was 17 this happened
and then when I was 21 you know I got
left at the altar what it you know
whatever it is that informs that story
then becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
but to understand that that story is
fundamentally untrue yes there's these
certain things happen to you they happen
to you amongst the untold trillions of
things that have happened to you over
the course of your life you just made a
decision to you decided that these were
important but you can just as easily
make a decision that other things can
hold that level of significance and hang
your hat on them to forge a new story
about what should or could happen when
you're in a particular scenario I see
what you're saying is what do you choose
to hardwire
right first of all do we have a choice
we do have a choice and our memory is
obviously selective based on our
emotional attitude and an overriding
agenda and some of it is unconscious
like if a trauma occurs it's correct
anchor itself it's gonna anchor and be
hardwired in but the bottom piece that I
work with in both in myself and in
advising others is pick a time every day
in which you're gonna actually dedicate
some of your life to rewiring some of
the hard wiring because it is that hard
wiring that's either epigenetically
involved or if you've suffered a trauma
in this lifetime it's there and that is
what you are basing memory off of
because the memory is constantly
relating back to those key points and
saying is this an additional component
that's like this and if so I need to
remember this mm-hmm because the brain
will always be going along with viewing
through the lens of what's hardwired in
that's forming that lens and so being
able to not be a false positive but
being able to be positive in this world
okay Julie and her friend Tamara were
you know on me one time when we were at
a gathering at your house and you know I
had just come in from you know being out
there in the world and experienced all
of these things and of course I'm not
you know
blind to what's going on in media and
news and you know and I was thinking you
know well the race is really on and I
was using that negativity to be very
stimulating and and your and your wife
and her good friend we're looking at me
and they were like working me over you
know at this gathering say no come on
man back to you back to your positive
self and it was really beautiful because
what I saw later was all right they saw
me in very rough water and they threw me
a life a life ring hmm
they said grab
onto this because you're in some really
rough water now and you want to have
this as you know an extra security and I
really love that and that was being
positive in a negative where I knew I
had to dive in and experience the
negative because if I didn't experience
it I wouldn't know what it was I
wouldn't know how it was affecting
people the key is not getting lost in a
direct right and that that requires a
certain level of awareness I mean I
think you know all you have to do is go
on Twitter and just scroll and you the
level of negativity is unbelievable
the level of the level of childishness
yes there's a lot of that yeah so the
point I'm trying to make is there's a
lot of people like you you have to have
a little bit of awareness to go okay I'm
being negative I gotta pull back or I
want to experience this negative impulse
so that I can use it as recall to fuel
my positive disposition moving forward
or whatever it is but without a without
that awareness you're just gonna be lost
and I think there's a lot of people who
are lost in their negative thought
patterns they're their victim
consciousness whatever it is and they're
not even consciously aware that that's
how they're proceeding through life like
if you sat them down and said look on
thirty occasions today you said you know
it never works out some version of like
it never works out for me I think most
people who kind of fit that mold would
be surprised to hear that mhm because
they're running on this loop that is
triggered in an unconscious way and so
and body and that is do they are so for
that personality type how does that how
does one begin the process of
deconstructing that how does that get
you where does that take you these are
the kinds of questions that a mirror
needs to reflect a partner a friend and
then ask of the world around it
- call me - call me out - you know how
do how does that protect you how does
that attitude protect you how does that
statement work for you those are not
attack phrases those aren't even
rhetorical questions in fact they're
actually honest questions and when you
come up with an answer to those things
and you go well it does this and it
makes me and then go a little deeper
well and and where does that go and I
find that if what my wife and I do with
each other is that we won't say hey man
you're being this way right now we'll
just say hmm how's that doing is that is
that something that you're consciously
choosing or and we start to key each
other and so I would advise people that
are listening or watching that you need
to have a buddy system you also need to
have a buddy system within yourself you
talked about like either on this or a
previous podcast about your experience
of 7 years with the artists way yeah
we're just doing a story doing inventory
doing morning pages doing a journaling
practice and finding out how does that
work for you either have someone call
you on it call yourself on it because I
find that if I get trapped in an
unconscious pattern I can go on for a
very long time and if that pattern is
helpful constructive productive it's a
good thing yeah it requires rigorous
honesty rigorous honesty from within
yourself and honesty on behalf of the
buddy if you're in the buddy system to
give you the the uncomfortable feedback
gotta be fearless people people a lot of
people don't like that yes but you've
got to get comfortable with that level
of honesty if you want to if you want to
graduate okay what you got to get
comfortable also with is a level of
reaction to your honesty and then you'll
get
more aware of how to deliver the honesty
because honesty deliver your the buddy
you mean yeah or even if you're your own
buddy you know how do you how do you
tell yourself that there is you did it
again how do you tell yourself that you
just did it for the umpteenth time and
you knew you were gonna do it and you
knew you were doing it and you knew you
did it and blah blah
you got to be your friend you got to be
able to be gentle in your Corrections
yeah I think what happens in real life
is that people who have a negative
disposition or play the victim card
generally aren't on the receiving end of
a lot of honest feedback if they are
they push that person away and most
people just won't say anything they'll
just kind of slowly move backwards until
that person becomes very isolated and
alone and this is because no one wants
to be around that person you used a good
word honesty because this is a form of
dishonesty isn't it what is to move back
and not to say anything not to be that
mirror I suppose I think people just
they get uncomfortable and they're just
like well I just don't you know some for
some people it's setting a healthy
boundary like I just don't I don't want
people like that in my orbit so I'm
moving in another direction it's not
malicious it's discretionary dishonest -
yeah I guess well do you have it do you
have it is it incumbent upon you to tell
that person there being a certain way
that feels like a transgression as well
yeah that is sort of modern
interpretation I think it's the way in
which it's done and the point at which
it's done and the kind of relationship
that you have with that person but I
even think that there's ways of stepping
into and I'm not saying dishonesty in a
in a condemning way but I think there's
ways of stepping into honesty stepping
into honesty in a neutral way that isn't
going to be conflicting with us with the
sanctity or the appropriateness of a
situation I think you have to be able to
be very conscious very intuitive as to
how that plays out and also be able to
have a you know step three and four
after you've taken step one and it
didn't go so well
you know be able to have a an apology in
place so that if you've stepped on toe
too harshly that you can you can you
know move to the apology as your step
two but I'm and then I think what will
end up happening is that you will like
the birds of a feather that that flock
together I think that you will end up
attracting those who want to know and be
moved away from those who want to hide
mm-hmm and I don't say hide meaning that
they're wrong or bad I just mean that
they they don't want to have that much
information in that moment I think the
crucial thing was somebody who's trying
to grow or overcome these kinds of
habits is that you have to be open and
willing to receive information about
your behavior that could be perceived as
critical in a way where you understand
it's not personal do you realize that
we've just turned the title around
because we started out by you know
positive in the negativity but now what
we're talking about is how to
successfully be negative in the
positivity that's beautiful I love it
because it is you know we're revolving
positives and negatives around a neutral
center and sometimes it's appropriate to
be positive sometimes negative and
sometimes in neutral
I mean you've raised children you've
raised beautiful creative I've taken
long drives with them I know who they
are I've met them I've heard them you
know in their creative moments and I've
done the same and so we know that there
is a great deal of time when you have to
be negative in the positive and you have
to be positive in the negative and then
there's other times when you have to be
completely neutral which is kind of what
you and I were working over you know
maybe three minutes five minutes ago is
it what about that neutrality
you know you said when you said I never
expected that to come out of you you
know yeah there is that that needs to
come out of each one of us and then
there are those times when would you say
transgressing then there are those times
when you really have to be that neutral
person that you will see that right now
there is no way in hell that any
statement from me is going to have any
beneficial effect I'm trying to
understand that explain that to me a
little bit more well when you're raising
children there's a time for positive and
there's a time for negative and then
there's also those times particularly
when they're in their adolescent stage
when neutrality is a little better way
of moving the game forward right I get
that it's to me it feels more like non
reactivity like I try to I think I think
having neutrality in how you deliver a
message whether that message is
inherently negative or positive is
important so I think neutrality is kind
of the overriding overarching theme with
which one should aspire to communicate
in terms of providing feedback on
somebody else's behavior thinking
inappropriate yeah
you've got to touch your own emotional
baggage from I love it otherwise you're
projecting your own [ __ ] on somebody
else you're right just what we're all
doing all the time anyway what is it
that the Yogi's said I don't know what
did the yogi say the only sound of many
things
the only sound of truth is the sound of
your inhale if you add anything to the
exhale it's your opinion oh that's
beautiful oh my god I'd never heard that
before
who said that specifically oh goes back
to known you know goes back so far it's
unknown you know but that was what they
would say that the sound of your inhale
is and that's why they said SOT is the
sound of that truths that that
nourishing inhale and then everything
after that everything after that is an
opinion yeah and then what are we even
talking about yeah you go but hey you
can't go to that state of neutrality you
would just sit and do nothing which is
what the Buddha had to do that's what
Jesus had to do it's what Krishna had to
do for those lengths of time it's what
the Yogi's did in the caves where they
would sit it's what the deep meditation
is is to sit in the total neutrality sit
in the total darkness sit in the total
you know encapsulation in order to come
up with that innovation I was talking to
a close family member and this person
was saying that that he was borderline
despondent like having a really hard
time like just swimming and drowning in
negativity and I said well what are you
doing like how do you spend your time
it's like well I watch tons of news like
like basically this person was saying
politics is what has him completely bent
out of shape and I'm like why do you you
don't have to watch the news you don't
have to be subsumed by the daily
discourse and drama
word but this person felt like they
couldn't hit the off switch on that so
there's I think it gets more complicated
because despite the awareness that that
this person has that this consumption of
this kind of content leads to this kind
of negative disposition the inability to
hit that switch and course-correct is in
part fueled by the fact that there's
something about that negative influx of
information or drama or whatever it is
that on some level is doing something
for that person otherwise they wouldn't
do it so there's something that's
working for them in the same way that
drugs and alcohol work for an alcoholic
or an addict it's not a it's not a great
thing to do but there's something about
it that's functioning for them you know
I think in order to really deconstruct
this you have to acknowledge that yes
and get to the bottom of what it is that
that is serving in order to figure a way
out that's healthier what it serves in
part at times not to create a gross
generality is safety if I know what's
happening in that world I mean when did
politics become the obsession I it
evolved over time it's now a competitive
sport this team and this team right who
got the win today but it's goes way back
it's attached to our physical body and I
need to survive calamity if we know
where all the danger points are and the
news will definitely feed that because
the news is for the most part bad news
or at least there is some bad in the
news I will know the danger points in my
world and I will then because I am got
my eye on those danger points don't take
your eye off the ball and if the ball is
the danger points and I've got my eye on
it continuously than I am safe and that
is what that obsession does for people
people feel that if they keep their eye
on that ball they will be safe and
that's why we've created these
opportunities for these charlatans these
hucksters to rise to the top of all of
these positions globally because that
was a ripe fertile field for them to
become the most demonstrative there's a
reason why the word demonstrative and
demon have the same root hmm yeah I mean
there's definitely something to that I
think it's also informed by our deep
desire to belong to a certain tribe hmm
so this sport of politics plays into
that base drive and then paying
attention to it allows us to shore up
our membership in whatever respective
camp we are Allegiant - yeah good word
tribe because it is a very primitive
function in the human psyche and the
psycho-emotional apparatus being tribal
and I've being very very it's a very
primitive very brutal also can be very
brutal as one tribe against another
tribe it's where it is really important
for us to be positive in the negative so
that we can at least lift ourselves out
for a moment to see okay is this a is
this a tribal activity that I am
consciously choosing to engage in or is
this a tribal activity that I have
swept into mm-hmm so to be positive to
be to be levitational in the gravity of
a situation is important so that you get
some distance and you can see before the
fact what is happening in fact yeah
what's the solution solution in my
estimation is to take time out time out
every day you could take time out while
you're preparing your food you could
take time out when you're relating to
your children you could take time out on
a morning walk or I wouldn't take time
out on a drive this you better be paying
attention to the road but you can take
time out in so many different ways I
take time out and deep meditation deep
deep meditation going into a dream time
where I'm not even aware of my physical
surroundings at least two or three times
each week I'll have to get into that
state for a extended period of time when
I say an extended period of time I mean
at least thirty minutes an hour and what
is the experience when you come out of
one of those sessions fresh refreshed
reboot it's kind of like you know
turning off your computer view or
turning off your phone because things
were jamming up and then all of a sudden
it's kind of like new again and that's
what happens when I come out of it I I
don't and this is good because I'm glad
you brought into the title and that that
neutral position and then what did you
say nonreactive because when I come out
of that I may not be neutral but I'm
definitely nonreactive
yeah and that becomes like a super power
super power isn't that interesting too
in today's world the probably the most
product the most profitable media
company right now is Marvel and begin
all they're doing is making things about
these super realistic sometimes very
unknown so is that realistic yeah just
these people with superpowers
because coming out with a fresh view of
what's going on in this world is being
positive in the negativity being
refreshed in the negativity not denying
the negativity but being able to at
least be able to survive the negativity
long enough to identify what the
negativity is and then going into your
creative factors coming up with a
solution that's wrong and you fail and
you forgive yourself and you come back
come up with another solution that may
or may not be right and you have to keep
you know trial and error until you come
up with a pathway through to navigate so
I would say that was perhaps one of the
most important reasons why I try to
maintain positivity in the negative
mm-hmm is to be able to navigate yeah
and I think with that developing that
acumen to be nonreactive
that's super power the more finally you
can hone that over time as your practice
matures
it's that non reactivity that gives you
that space to objectively assess not
just your environment and the stimuli
that's coming at you but also your own
behavior so that you are more apt and
able to catch yourself falling prey to
one of those negative looping you know
behaviors or actions or phrases that
come out of your mouth to have the
awareness and say oh I did it again look
I just did it as opposed to being on
autopilot where you're doing it and you
don't even know that you're doing it
yeah as you were telling that I was just
thinking about some scenarios in my
world where I would repeat patterns
right and we all do know that I was
going to get into that same hole so I at
one point in time there was this pattern
that when I'm in a meeting that has you
know more than three or four people in
it you know it's like a it's like a
board meeting or a group meeting or an
organizational meeting and I just see
the whole thing going stupid
and I'm thinking look at I can't be the
only smart person in the world in the
room right now but what I see is really
ridiculous and I would come out with
what I thought was a solution to the
ridiculousness and then the whole room
would turn on me okay I did it again you
know and I kept and I kept working this
for year after year decade at because
you know we've been through a few
meetings right at this age and finally I
just said you know what this is an
unsolvable riddle so I'm just gonna go
for it and so the last meeting that I
used this technique in I used it to the
nth degree I said I really came to the
point where I just turned to the whole
room and said are we really gonna be
this ridiculously stupid and go down
this path and I was I was raising my
voice and I was standing up and sitting
down we were all sitting around a big
circular table and I afterwards people
just sort of like what that just
happened and I thought this is good I no
longer have to be in these rooms I
graduated so then you're out there like
I am out if I find myself in a situation
in which I am reacting and no matter
what I've done over years and years I'm
still not improving on that I say could
who sing you better listen to what's
here because you have this perspective
that you think that that activity or
that attitude is wrong you've never been
able to change it and so now let's go on
the opposite direction and what I found
was I am now where I'm supposed to be
and I'm no longer finding myself in
those rooms I'm in rooms I'm in groups
I'm in people I'm with people but for
some reason I was
holding myself in those kinds of
settings that would just totally
aggravate me until I realized I didn't
have to put up with them I didn't have
to go nice with them I didn't have to be
that tolerant voice with them I just had
to blow myself up in the middle of them
so that I would never get back into the
middle well that's one that's one way of
going about it I guess I mean what is
that what's the take away from that if
your body is telling you if your gut is
telling you that the negativity that
you're feeling and the positivity that
you're trying to display in the midst of
that negativity isn't working and hasn't
been working then you need to go with
your gut and you need to not necessarily
like in an abrupt way and telling
everybody that they're totally messed up
way but in a gentle way you need to
start moving yourself out of the orbits
that you're currently in and give
yourself if it's a work setting give
yourself some runway if it's a social
setting give yourself some runway and
allow yourself to gently work your way
out of those situations in which you
feel like being a positive force in a
negative situation is never appreciated
mmm oh my god because it sounds like you
just blew the whole thing up idea and
then you're like nah I never have to go
back there again then oh I didn't blow
it yeah I didn't blow it up you blob
your place in the I blew its receptivity
to me being a part of it mm-hmm and I
had to do that not because they were
unable I had to do it because I had been
unable for all those decades to step out
of that not I'm not talking about a
specific setting but to be able to step
out of that kind of setting and not
subject myself to it I mean people all
the time are saying you know well I I
should put up with it
I should be new
trol right I should be even I should be
nonreactive
I should just not cause waves no at some
point in time the most positive thing
you can do is to be super negative what
I get out of that is is the negativity
the frustration the depression whatever
kind of negative impulse related
emotions arise often come from
situations in which we feel powerless
right so we we can rage against politics
or you know your sports team that never
wins or whatever whatever it is
something that we fundamentally can't
control or direct right is a source of
pain and frustration and all of these
emotions that I just said and a way
forward is to try to release your
attachment to those things to
fundamentally understand that you don't
have control over them it's kind of a
relief if you can connect with that and
instead focus on the things that you can
control you can control whether you're
gonna be a member of that meeting that
board or whatever it is and you have
control over whether you attend or not
you don't have control over the group
consensus you can attempt to influence
it which you did many times it caused
you consternation and frustration until
you like have these outbursts so the
thing you can control is your
involvement right similarly we can't
control politics we can control how much
politics we consume mmm to use that
example some good examples right we can
control how we move our body what we put
in our mouths we can control our various
behaviors we can't control other people
scenarios situations there's actually
very little that we can control but the
more energy we place and invest in those
few things that we can control I think
is a is a positive path forward to
cultivating the positive mental attitude
that we all seek to embody
so every time we eat putting the right
food in our body yeah we have a choice
are we gonna put high vibration food
into our body or we're gonna eat junk
food that we know is going to make us
depressed and every time that we have a
moment that we could exercise or slouch
we have a choice it doesn't mean that
you have to exercise every moment that
you have a free moment and it doesn't
mean that you can't eat a bit of junk
you know that really tastes good every
once in a while not to be fanatic but
you've got to have a majority of your
time consuming whether it's eating or
listening or seeing positivity otherwise
you're going to be just another
contributor and the negative result that
in the situation of stimuli coming at
you you have a choice to react
impulsively or to respond mindfully like
don't be don't have your mouth open in a
food fight
make choices easier said than Donald
easier said than done but the idea that
and one of the things that I would like
to get across to the listeners and
viewers is that sometimes what appears
to be negative is the most positive
thing you can do what appears to be safe
is sometimes the most dangerous thing
you can be doing for your life plan you
develop awareness over what is the
correct move what we were just talking
about are some of the fundamental small
moves the small initial moves eat right
sleep right exercise right sleep right
is really important
trying to bait you with it we're not
going to go down the gravity blanket
right yet but eat right sleep right
exercise right and then you know start
to monitor start to discipline your
think write your speak right you know
and every once in a while just blow it
all up and see if it comes
together in a Nashville I don't mean you
know literally but just you know rock
your boat every once in a while rock
your boat don't be all you know held
together and get creative I think that's
a good place to end it rock your boat
rock your boat is that the name of the
song you're gonna play for us right now
oh hey you're gonna take us out again
right I'm gonna take you down another
path right on bro and this one is in the
this one is the is is a bit of the
non-reaction
[Music]
[Applause]
that we were talking about the bit of
the neutrality and the word confidence
means confidence fie dance means faith
to be confident that the infinite will
take care of it
we're so fortunate
[Music]
be confident
we'll take care of it with fortune
[Music]
much love my brother much much love
bless you let's do it again next time do
it again soon all right peace
plants namaste
[Music]